hört man diesen Müllwagen
hallo ihr Lieben wir machen heute eine white
chocolate Tat mit Kokos und das ganze in den
no back Variante und zwar ohne eine spezielle
tatform also es wird ein sehr einfaches schnelles
und unglaublich leckeres Rezept ich mache jetzt
zuallererst mal einen Keksboden und ihr wisst
ja bei meinen Videos schreibe ich euch die ganz
genauen Mengenangaben immer unten in die genau
so die Kekse werden jetzt schön fein gemahlen
Butter habe ich gerade schon in der Mikrowelle
zerlassen nimmt da immer lieber die
geringe Wattzahl also lieber 360 Watt
oder sowas bevor die Butter euch platzt
und die ganze Mikrowelle eingesaut ist
und sobald ihr das dann gemixt habt könnt ihr
die Butter hinzugeben und alles gut vermengen
so der Keksboden ist soweit jetzt habe ich hier
einen Tortenring damit könnt ihr nämlich auch
ganz einfach eine schöne Tarte zubereiten ihr
habt da halt nur nicht diese Wellen außenrum
aber ich finde die braucht es auch gar nicht
so ich stelle meinen Tortenring ein auf 22 cm
zack ich packe meinen Koffer Tonlage ne so 22 cm
braucht ihr dann braucht den Backpapier beachtet
bitte nicht die vielen Logos das ist das aus der
Gastro aus dem Kaffee aber ich habe kein normales
Backpapier mehr zu Hause gehabt so und jetzt schon
mal ein einfach damit es nicht nervt und einfach
schön eng anliegend ist braucht ihr eigentlich
nicht weil es ist ja nichts was ausläuft ihr
macht einfach nur Keksboden rein aber das hier
könnt ihr jetzt euch auch noch mal merken für
flüssigere Teige weil mit dem Torten könnt ihr
natürlich auch Backen der ist hitzebeständig
auch die Klemmung hier vorne und dann müsstet
ihr quasi immer wieder dass wir von außen nach
innen knicken so ist ja einmal im Kreis angekommen
seid und dann seid ihr eigentlich schon fertig so
um das gleiche transportieren habe ich jetzt hier
noch ein cakeboard unten drunter und jetzt füllt
ihr den kompletten Keksboden einmal ein und dann
müssen wir einen ja so wie hoch ist das gut dass
ich diese Zentimeter Angaben innen habe das
ich sage ja das ist ein richtiger Game change
ich persönlich aufgefallen ich habe so Geräusche
gehört aber ich dachte zu nerven du bist schon
überleben also ich würde sagen macht den Rand
so 3 cm hoch also erstmal verteile ich das hier
gleichmäßig später nehme ich mir auch noch ein
Glasboden um das schön flach anzudrücken und dann
könnt ihr das eigentlich das funktioniert
immer am besten mit den sauberen Händen
nee die Hände wäscht man sich nicht eigentlich
hier so ein Rand andrücken und den dann noch
mal begradigen wir füllen ja gleich noch mal
so eine richtig leckere Kokos Pudding Füllung
ein und die muss nicht komplett abschließen
mit dem Rand also die ragt auch noch so ein
bisschen drüber daher braucht es nicht
so genau nee macht einfach nach Gefühl
so der Boden ist soweit fertig ihr könnt
jetzt entweder bis zur Weiterverarbeitung
in den Kühlschrank stellen dann sitzt
alles noch mal schön oder einfach an
die Seite geben weil das ganze wirklich
sowieso noch gekühlt übrigens findet Ihr
nicht nur alle ganz genauen Mengenangaben
in der Infobox sondern auch mein Equipment
wie zum Beispiel den Tortenring etc und alles
was ihr dann noch so benötigen könntet und wir
haben sogar auf der Webseite immer oben auf
der Leiste unseren aktuellen Rabattcode das
heißt den könnt ihr dann auch noch nutzen und
sogar was sparen so ich mache jetzt hier die
kokosfüllung mit weißer Schokolade dafür
habe ich die weiße die weiße zahnkultur
nein dafür habe ich die weiße Kuvertüre fein
gehackt ihr könntet jetzt auch einfach Tafel
Schokolade nehmen also es muss jetzt
nicht unbedingt Kuvertüre sein ich
nehme immer das was ich gerade da habe
so dann bin ich hier am Herd habe jetzt
meine Pfanne genommen eigentlich
würde ich jetzt ohne Kamera mein
Topf nehmen aber in der Pfanne habe ich
das Gefühl seht ihr einfach besser bzw
einfach nur rein tun den Herd noch nicht
einschalten weil die Speisestärke muss
ich jetzt erstmal mit der Milch
verbinden da könnt ihr aber jetzt
gleich auch schon direkt Vanilleextrakt mit
dazugeben einfach für den guten Geschmack
ach liebe das so und da einfach noch
mal mit dem Schneebesen reingehen alles
Klümpchen frei verrühren und dann könnt
ihr den Herd einschalten und das ganze
Jahr quasi aufkochen lassen immer rühren
damit da nichts anbrennen wobei ich sagen
muss weil mein Fondant sowieso die was
an aber dann könnt ihr anschließend auch
schon Kokosraspeln mit dazu geben wenn
ihr merkt das dick zu allmählich ein
nachdem das Ganze einmal aufkocht liegt das auch
schon ein und ihr könnt den Herd ausschalten und
die weiße Kuvertüre einfach in der Resthitze
schmelzen lassen das Ganze lasse ich dann 5
Minuten ausdampfen und gebe dann Mascarpone
dazu ihr merkt auch dass sich alles dann so
von beige auf ich würde sagen weiß aber
auf heller verfärbt durch die Mascarpone
und die locker hat das Ganze auch noch mal
ein bisschen auf gerade auch im Anschnitt
so und jetzt gebe ich einfach nur noch die
kokosfüllung quasi in den Tortenring und dann
einmal glatt verstreichen und am besten kühlt
ihr das jetzt so ca 4 Stunden ihr könnt solche
Geschichten aber auch immer am Vorabend schon
vorbereiten und dann halt über Nacht kühlen
und dann fehlt ja eigentlich nur noch gleich
unsere weiße Schokoladenglasur und die Deko
nach der Kühlzeit machen wir die schöne
Glasur davon nehmen wir uns einfach nur
weiße Schokolade oder weiße Kuvertüre und
Sahne ich empfehle euch aber auf jeden Fall
ein Schmelztopf zu benutzen weil gerade
bei weißer Schokolade ist es so dass sie
sehr schnell klumpt und ihr dann eben nicht
so eine schöne feine Glasur habt also gerne
über einem Wasserbad einfach Wasser erhitzen
Schmelztopf oben drauf geben und dann langsam
langsam das Schmerzen lassen so das gebe ich
jetzt hier einmal auf die kalte Oberfläche und
dann werde ich das wahrscheinlich schwenkend
hin und her schieben ihr könnt es aber auch
mit einem mit einer Winkel Palette einfach
machen und sobald das dann noch mal abgekühlt
ist dann gebe ich noch mal für 10 Minuten in
den Kühlschrank kommt die Deko und da werde
ich dann wahrscheinlich das nehme ich denn da
ach weißt du was lass mich selber überraschen
die weiße Glasur ist jetzt extra noch cremig
also wenn ihr schneidet ist sie nicht so knackig
das wollte ich nämlich nicht und jetzt müssen
wir aber zuerst mal den Tortenring lösen die
jetzt hier mein Backform Löser und gerade
weil wir jetzt auch am Rand noch mal mit
diesem Keksboden hochgegangen sind ist es ganz
wichtig dass ihr das wirklich ganz vorsichtig
erstmal löst und dann den Ring entfernt weil
wenn ihr jetzt den Ring einfach abnimmt dann
reißt euch das quasi einfach komplett durch
und dann war die ganze Mühe umsonst einmal eine
schöne Runde man spürt auch richtig wie dieser
Boden so abgeht und sich vom Tortenring löst
ich liebe man diesen Moment wenn man den
Tortenring hochzieht das war mein Magic Moment
doch genau so wollte ich ihn haben so war ja
auch bei mir in meinem Rezept Test dass man
einfach echt noch so viel vom Keksboden sieht
aber das eben richtig toll abschließt mit dem
weißen ich finde es auch richtig hübsch das
werde ich das einmal transferieren auf mein
Port und dann schneide ich das in Stückchen denke
mal da kann man locker 12 Stücke rausschneiden
so mit dem cakeboard könnt ihr jetzt hier
natürlich auch ganz easy peasy unten drunter
viele sagen ja man geht das dann so einfach oder
klebt das dann fest nee guck mal das geht so
einfach zack einmal runter nehmen Backpapier
weg und dann hier einfach drauf schieben
so ich dekoriere jetzt übrigens noch mit
Kokosraspeln ich überlege noch Kokos Chips
mit dazu zu nehmen aber hier noch dieses
beige muss mal gucken wie es aussieht und
was ich auf jeden Fall dazu nehme einfach weil
ich finde es passt und was auch farblich gut
aussieht gefriergetrocknete Erdbeeren das ist ja
leider keine Saison sonst hätte ich auch frische
Erdbeeren genommen aber gefriergetrocknete
Erdbeeren sind einfach erntefrische Erdbeeren
die gefriergetrocknet werden das heißt es wird
das ganze Wasser entzogen und was bleibt sind
richtig knackige in unserem Fall jetzt
halbierte Erdbeeren die schmecken so süß
und so richtig richtig lecker im Auto snicke
ich immer so eine ganze Packung ganz alleine
weg aber wie gesagt darum soll es jetzt nicht
gehen wir machen das jetzt einfach als Deko
noch mal auf unsere Torte und vorher teile ich
das aber ja schauen wir mal durch 12 oder 14
boah junge Mädel was machst du mit mir
was machst du mir so dann lass uns mal
das Gute Stückchen probieren ich finde es
auch richtig schön serviert ne weiß aber
ja mega schön so tut mir leid ich muss
nur ein ein Foto machen bitte natürlich
bei der Glasur ich habe gesagt die ist extra schön
weich und wenn ihr die Stücke schon anschneidet
bei dir sieht man es richtig dann läuft die Glasur
mit der Zeit echt noch mal so runter an der Seite
so frisch das schmeckt so frisch
mega gut und das gute ist ja kein
zusätzlichen Zucker hier im in der
Füllung weil wir haben schon die Süße aus
der Schokolade wir haben die Kokosraspeln
also ich wusste ja dass der gut schmeckt aber
wenn man ihn dann noch mal richtig gekühlt ist
die Kokosraspeln in dieser Creme die geben
so diesen kleinen Crunch ich mag das voll
ja und Crunch hast du auch noch mal im Boden ich
finde das bodenfüllung gussverhältnis 12 und 10
Leute ich mache das auf jeden Fall
öfter ich sage euch wirklich gegessen
also wer den nicht nachmacht hat
selber schuld weil er was verpasst
hat also dann würde ich mal behaupten
bis zum nächsten Mal auf die Kinder
seid weil ich muss ehrlich sagen ich will du weißt
ich bin white verrückt ne Sneaker muss ich sofort
probieren alles mögliche in white da bin ich immer
voll mit dabei vielleicht kommt der bald etwas
Spoiler ich würde mal sagen bis
zum nächsten mal ganz kurz raus
und dann weißt Du so drauf gerade
also Leute viel Spaß Leute nachmachen